hey how's it going guys welcome back to
code tech tutorials and
we're going to do a video today about a
comment that i just got an hour ago
because it's a great topic that i
haven't covered before and it's
something easy for me to do
while i'm preparing a lot of other
things and that is
on a blender video editing basics guide
someone asked well
loot hammer blonde hammer i don't know
so
if you have two videos that you want to
make into one showing side by side
how would one do that i can answer that
and i'll show you here in blender but
first
i've been doing these pulls recently i
just want to flip through them real
quick show you guys on here
uh so to the question when stuck on a
problem
that has a firm deadline what do you do
most people asked or most people
responded with research more and come
back closer to the deadline
true scientists here keep on researching
i love you guys
uh the other ones were interesting too
some people definitely just accept
defeat or make memes about it
yeah i get it sometimes you don't care
that much about the question i've been
there
or take a guess let the deadline hit see
if you're close this is what i do on
tests pretty much
if you don't have the ability to go
research more you just gotta take a
guess
uh two percent of people do that in real
world now this is really interesting and
i know the stop topic from blender but
i'll get to blender and i'll leave a
mark for you if you want to skip right
to it and
don't care about this stuff but this is
something that's been uh churning for
like a week so i feel like i need to
just make a video about it all right
this is kind of one of the problems with
school and maybe i'll make a deeper
subject about this
if people are interested but you see
only two percent of people do this in
real life
but when you're in school you pretty
much have to do this all
the time anytime you have a test you
just like i'm guessing i'm guessing
unless you know but before that yeah
you're researching
keep staring at the question thinking my
brain will magically i think this is
supposed to make a connection people got
it
yeah just staring at the question
sometimes i reread it a lot
i wonder if i uh read it wrong or
something or if it's just going to click
but yeah i think this uh this first one
is pretty obvious that's
that's awesome but yeah
this uh let the deadline hit see if
you're close
that's just taking tests basically and
it's interesting to see that nobody
actually does that tests are not that
realistic
anyway let's move on what operating
system do you use for work
now this i didn't expect to see i really
thought mac os
would be higher than linux to see that
most people use windows which is
understandable
but linux just absolutely destroying
mac os really surprised me
i don't know what to make of this really
i guess it's cool
it's the time to sell all our apple
stock all right um
maybe i should make a programming story
about how to trade stocks or digital
currency with c
plus or should i most people just said
yeah do it
and uh i plan on it
though this is tricky to get right um
really tricky to get right
so give me a couple weeks i think i'll i
think i'll have something i might do it
in phases
once i'm because there's like certain
things you need to know
first before you can really start like
for example just using the internet in
general with c plus plus so i'll
probably make a tutorial on that
on how to generally connect to websites
and full data and stuff like that
there's so many different ways to do it
alright let's get to the blender
tutorial
here we go so we're opening blender i
just downloaded and installed the latest
version so this should be
very fresh uh what's it doing it's grey
screen
there we go all right this is new to me
2.91.2
very very new
okay so we're gonna kind of play around
here i'm just gonna go up here see if
they got video editing yep they do
let's go to video editing cool let's go
set our settings first
file format ffmpeg output i'm going to
change to
my render area which is over here
under rendered set
and this one's important too encoding
audio aac all right we're done there so
let's go ahead and save
actually i'm going to do a save as
and we'll call this video
editing template
so that's a nice thing to do if you
haven't done that yet just get all your
base settings that you always want
and then do a save as so you can load
this one up
and then once you start doing your edits
you do another save as okay so let's
grab a few small videos and i'll show
you how to do the split thing
i'm just going to grab some small videos
from my previous few videos just clips
and stuff so there's this one about the
software gore and there's some other one
here
i think i did on my game engine right
here and all you do is you just bring
them in
now they do have to be the same frame
way right if these are
different frame rates this won't work so
if you've got videos from different
devices
the first thing you want to do is open
up handbrake
and convert both your videos with
handbrake to be the same
type the same frame rate that way you
can do this so
just just know that first it's really
important if you miss that step you'll
just be stuck
so we now have two videos here if we
play now we'll get the overlapping audio
and the the video that's on top
will show this other one will be hidden
but what we want to do is put one on the
left
one on the right or we could do one on
the top one on the bottom
it doesn't matter a whole lot and the
way we can do that
as well i guess you have to ask how much
you care about the audio because if you
don't care about the audio you can just
delete it
and if you're only using the video
uh i guess i'll leave the audio in in my
case but you want to keep this overlap
the same we'll just go out to like 20
seconds
and i'm going to stop it here so i'm
going to mark my end frame as this one
i'm at
1 6 6 7 just put it up here paste it
there we go
so we're only going to make it this long
no need to make it super long just to
show off uh
all right very good so what we want to
do at this point is basically add some
transformations to the video
so you click on your video you know what
i'm just going to cut this right here
so i'm going to select all these just
hold ctrl shift
select them all press k for cut
grab all these ones delete now i'm just
doing this just to
clean it up a little bit so i'm working
with nice even strips
but it doesn't necessarily matter you
could layer a short one on top of a
another one and use stuff it's a lot to
explain but i'll just get to it all
right let's uh
so we click on this video clip on top
you can do it with the bottom first but
it's easier to see the top one you can't
really see the bottom one right now
so i'm going to press shift a and bring
up
this add menu and we're going to go
effect strip transform so now we have a
transform
connected to this video and we start
transforming it
over here with its uh strip stuff
so i can move it to the left move to the
right move it up and down
it's all good i can scale it which is
probably what you're going to need to do
do the scale i'm going to keep it
uniform so let's go ahead and do this
now you'll see you can't see the one
behind it yet
that's fine so however you want to do
this is up to you i'm just going to do a
scale like this
and now if you don't want some of the
sides like maybe you want to make a nice
square side you could
size you could go crop and you can cut
off some of these so
let me check crop you can crop some of
the size it's not working like i thought
it would
uh maybe you have to do it on the other
line video but you can cut off sides of
the video
too so
oh let me check this maybe it's offset
let's
check the offset but you can play around
with these two to get your video there
we go that's how you crop the size with
offset not crop
which sounds backwards all right so you
can kind of like chop
sides if you want it to be a certain
that's sort of unrelated but you might
want to do that if you're
taking a 1080p video and only want it to
cover half the stream
screen size you might want to corrupt
some of it so
so let's scale this back up a little bit
so let's just say for example
i know a great pause frame right there i
mean my face just
uh okay let's set these back to zero so
let's do a thing where we actually mess
with this offset
so let's cut some of this over here
and then we can use crop to bring it
back over
so you got to use kind of a combination
of crop and offset so basically i just
want to get to the center here
oh oh i went way too far there we go
so maybe something like that i don't
know okay that's good enough
now let's move it all the way over here
and say this is my right side video so
i'm going to grab
all this and just move it up a little
bit
i press g then y after selecting those g
y move it up there it goes
and we want to do the same thing over
here ctrl a
on this bottom video clip effect strip
transform
uh uniform scale we can do crop and
offset but you can't see it
because it's underneath and this one up
here is set
to let's find it
there's that replace now um
this transform strip will replace
anything underneath it doesn't show
through
the things behind it with opacity and to
do that you got to change this replace
to overdrop and then you start seeing
all the stuff
behind it that's not covering it's just
an overdrop
kind of same thing you want to do with
pictures and stuff all right so we click
on the bottom transform which we can now
kind of see and you basically just want
to play around with these two you get it
how you like it
um there's like a lot there's a lot you
can do
it's really you know up to your own
creativeness what you do with this but
if you wanted to make it nice even what
i would do is something along the lines
of
i don't know say i wanted my i don't
know half my face there
crop a little bit more of that left side
get it to about
there except i want to bring myself back
over so go like this with the crop
and i don't know maybe right about there
and we can even bring it over a little
bit more
like that i don't know it's pretty close
but you can see we're using offset we're
using crop
just using the x's in this case on the
left
and we use the position and we used a
little bit of scale
that's about it and make sure you set it
to overdrop now let's go back to this
bottom one and let's mess with it some
uh so let's uh first of all just move it
over
like so let's see if i can get my face
in it maybe i'll go to about
here and i'll want something like that
and i guess i don't need to do a whole
lot else
because it's only the one on top that
you need to crop the other one's going
to be covered anyway
so like that should be good we could add
in a little special effect of like
something in the center of a separator
bar or something you could do that with
an overlay
lay picture or you could do that by
adding something like
go add color and you can use this little
text block
or color block thing here i'm not going
to do the color block
but another thing you do is you just
open up [ __ ]
and make yourself your a proper frame
within
an image so a little mix of tools here
with [ __ ] gimp's very common to use
along with other video editing i guess a
lot of people use photoshop
but we'll make a new 1080 image
um we're going to make a new layer
delete the old one
we just wanted a layer with opacity
and let's say we just do like a box
here right about the center and we're
just going to fill this box in and make
it like a separator bar
so what i'm going to do here is uh and
you can do this however you want
you just fill it in with a bucket color
or
you could also go to gradient i like to
do gradient for this and use something
like one of these
and then you can like well that's uh
radial we don't want radial let's go
linear you can do something like this
and give it kind of a
like a texture you see how it goes from
like gray to white kind of like it's a
metal bar or something all right well
that's good enough this is just an
example
go to export as it's going to call it
border or uh
enter bar real quick
not going to save this permanently but
just for sake for example and now we can
go
here you can you can use your file
explorer for your computer and drag it
in or you can use
this right here and this is where i just
saved it so it should now show up
uh you do have to hit refresh though and
there it is
inner bar so dragging the enter bar
um i guess we want it to be all the way
on top so let's make a little more space
drag this up here and we do want to
extend it to the beginning or in the end
or however long we want it to match so
you can grab these little ends here that
are different color
press g and if you hold ctrl it'll snap
and there you go so now we got two
separate videos with a separator part
separator bars optional and you can play
around from with it from there adjust it
how you need
but that's in general how you get two
videos playing at the same time and i'm
going to go ahead and hit play here and
we're going to see what it sounds like
let's see we're both talking at once so
you take this audio clip you
either just reduce the volume like that
or you could just delete the volume
of those if you don't need those if
you're talking over it and showing some
example of something completely
different you know
uh so that's basically how you do it we
i think we've got
about everything there of how to do it
you know there's another thing where you
can have like a big main screen and you
could do a picture and picture of a
small one
it's generally the same concept you just
take the overlay of one
size it down put it in the corner and it
looks like a little picture in pictures
so you can do a lot of cool little
effects with this
sort of setup with just using that
transform adjusting the crop offset and
all
and all that so yeah there you go i
think that covers it let me know if you
have any questions down below
uh people always ask how do you actually
get the results how do you save this
video uh so i'll show you that at the
end
you just go to render and render
animation
and that will save your video to
let's see wherever you put it in these
settings
so from this output properties
over on this properties tab
it's going to save it to rendered it's
going to save it as an ffmpeg
and it's going to do the video like so
audio like so so it's all how you set
this up
so that's where we go to render render
animation and we're going to get those
results it should be a pretty quick one
i'm not going to save it though i
rendered a tiny bit of it
but that's how you would render when
you're done in case you don't know
and i think that's pretty much it for
this video thank you so much for
watching
matt from code tech and tutorials over
and out appreciate you guys watching my
videos and commenting and liking all
that stuff
love you see you in the next one peace
out